the salty caramel rice krispies treat
was our first original recipe we love it
because it's caramel e it's gooey it's
light and it's delicious I'm Natalie
Potter and I'm Laura Potter and we're
the mother/daughter duo behind the
online rice krispie treat companies
listen Baker to start you're going to
prepare a pan with parchment paper and
we also sprinkle a tablespoon of sugar
on the bottom to prevent it from
sticking when you're making rice
krispies treats you're going to want to
use a nonstick pot you'll thank us later
for this when you're cleaning up the
nonstick is a total time-saver we prefer
to use salted butter because it adds
another depth of flavor I love rice
krispies treats because I believe they
are the best dessert on the entire
planet I think they're really nostalgic
it just seems like everybody enjoys them
we're gonna let all this cook for a few
minutes and you can tell it's done when
it can coat the back of your spoon
should take about five minutes reduce
the heat to low and add the mini
marshmallows we prefer to use mini
marshmallows over the larger ones
because they melt super fast and evenly
now we're gonna stir the marshmallows
together until they have completely
melted now that the pot is off the heat
it's time to add the rice cereal it's
really important that you fold in the
cereal to keep it from getting crushed
otherwise it can lead to a dense treat
and what we're really looking for is
something light and airy and chewy I
wish you guys could smell this it smells
so so good when you're smoothing out the
edges of the mixture be careful not to
press down too much so you can keep it
really light then you'll sprinkle flaky
sea salt on the top now the waiting game
I know you really want to eat these but
they're gonna take about an hour at room
temperature or if you're really excited
you could pop them in the fridge for
about 30 minutes I love getting to work
with my mom I'm just so grateful to have
this special relationship and have all
these new experiences and reach our
goals together we really hope that
people try this recipe and use these
tips to take their crispy game to the
next level we fully believe that
handmade treats have this magical power
to show people you love them and make
them happy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh oh yes
[Music]